[Music]
three
two one action hey guys welcome back to
off the record
we talk about
are those are racing glasses snowboard
goggles oh thank you i got it for 30
on amazon solar panels that charge your
brain you look like
cyclops if you pull it up your lips
thank you very much
they feel good indoors too yeah i like
them a lot
um because they're good hater blockers
all the [ __ ] haters be blocking
no it um yeah it's really good because
it's got that glare protection and
things like that
and then when you go downhill and you
get all this dust and stuff oh yeah
because you've been
biking a lot yeah it's very fun and so
he's like the adventure man of the group
now he's like the youngest one
yeah i'm like the oldest but they're
like the youngest happy
he's not married no kids i know that's
true which is crazy
because um i'm able to kind of continue
where i left off
in everything like in strategy and life
and all this stuff
and i was kind of like contemplating
like
what about some van life what about like
why do i have this big-ass house like by
myself
like i think our generation
is starting to question a lot of the
wastefulness right
like just like minimalism is hot like
all this stuff is cool right
and then i'm like yo man my spot is like
four plus grand a month
that's that's a lot for just by myself
and
i'm never home or well i am home but
like i don't know it's like i don't need
all that space
what am i going to do with it i don't
know
if you keep that place empty and it
still be so you gotta like fill it with
like a mountain bike
fill it with like a paddle board you
know adventure fill it with adventure
yeah i don't know man i i i just want to
see what it's like to be a homeless dude
i could see you live in the van life
yeah just go wherever you want
yeah whether it's mountains or beach
bring all your stuff with you a lot of
those guys they got wi-fi hooked up in
there so you could work on
what yeah and then you uh so we have a
friend um
volkswagen vanigan's now he has a
sprinter van it's
huge hooked up yeah yeah yeah so he has
a sprinter van that has a queen-size
mattress it's completely hooked up and
he also has these like
dry cell batteries or something so if he
wanted to go
literally off the grid into the woods he
has
enough power for ac and wi-fi to last
them 14 days straight
oh two weeks yeah so he's like i can
just go literally off the grid where no
one could ever find me but i still have
wi-fi and i have ac
in the in the thing well what are these
batteries they last in four
weeks it's like a box it's like the size
of this table that he had so he has uh
the back part of his van is two stories
so he has his mattress up top
on the bottom he has this giant battery
thing that puts at the bottom
wait so how long does it take to
recharge because like you charge it one
time it's
solar [ __ ] wait so how's it only
last in two weeks
i don't know because it costs because
it's it's you're gonna waste it at the
speed that it's charging
once he has it fully charged and he has
the solar panels running he can go out
into the woods for two
that's what i'm saying he's only gotta
charge it one time two weeks two weeks
that's a month you don't have to pay
rent
you waste more if you have the ac on you
waste more than you pay the car payment
solar you could go somewhere where you
don't say as fast as charging is
depleting
like you ever been on your phone you're
charging it and then you're [ __ ]
going crazy never goes up and then
they're like wait how come it's not
really charging
that's like my bank account by paying
rent
what you know what i mean it's like you
like make money like spend it on stuff
yeah yeah yeah like that yeah yeah yeah
so it's like so if you have your van on
full blast
uh it's gonna char it's gonna waste the
power way faster
so ac is the problem you see at night so
it's like hot unless you get like a
little vent or something so that's why
he has to have those batteries so it has
unless you drive somewhere cooler yeah
that's what i was saying
escape the heatwave are those fans that
you could fill with ice and then
give you your name he has fans too you
know what else he has you know you ever
seen the i got fans but they keep me i
got a third world van here
no no no they actually sell these ac
units
i've been looking into them for outdoors
but i'm like i don't want to have
like a full-on like ac unit because
they're also really big so i was looking
into these fans that they have these
compartments underneath the fan that you
actually fill up with water and ice
swamp cool it gives you yeah swamp
coolers are sick
yeah but you gotta keep clean actual fat
you know like on the house
to event ventilate your attic there's
those spinning metal things
yeah yeah he has like two or three
installed on top of his van
oh [ __ ] so it's like by the way the
science behind that i don't get it but
it's really cool
the ventilation yeah the ventilation
just heat rises yeah but then it just
why do you need to have the fan you
don't need to know the science dude
it has an escape yeah it's like a vent
yeah sucks the
the hot air it creates the motion of the
air to go up
because stale air and especially if it
gets hot it just [ __ ] no i don't
think it creates motion for the air to
go out i think the air pushes it and
creates the fan to push
then why have the fans there that's what
i'm saying to know if it's working or
not
i don't know because because like i have
that at
our studio right but you don't turn on
the fans they just spin when it starts
spinning
yeah so if there's heat in there it'll
spin that's why some areas the fans will
spin fast and some they don't spin as
fast that's where the air is at but
that's why i'm like what's the science i
don't know how it works
it just starts causing it to spin that
just starts moving quicker
and then it just picks up its own speed
science you know what i'm really
interested in
like super right now where i'm like we
need to talk about this what
nadine's teeth like what the hell look
at that smile
i didn't realize that how can you not
it's like so
like but the cool thing is like a lot of
people like
so the people that know me they're like
oh [ __ ] like that looks nice it looks
crazy but i have other people that are
coming up to me they're just like
because then they heard someone else
talking about they're like dude i wanted
to say you have a perfect spot like what
do you use
i'm like oh i actually got like crowns
in and they're like what like they're
like it looks natural it looks real i'm
like okay veneers
so like full veneers oh veneers are like
just the outside this
goes all the way around they look like
movie star team oh yeah movie star tv i
feel like are super straight
those are pretty stupid really strange
and they're really white
and bright and like just like how was
your teeth experience
it was good so like you went to turkey
yeah i want a turkey to get it done so
it's like cheaper you're happy to show
your smile now
yeah like i'm always constantly smiling
give us a big one
teeth like that you saw what draw tv
yeah compared to what they were it's
like a huge difference
for me it's like brought like a lot more
confidence because the cool thing is
like
i grew up with like i used to never
smile on photos and stuff like that then
i like gained the confidence to to talk
to people and everything
but then i still wanted them fixed so i
got them fixed so i was like okay i'm
happy now that's
that's cool man it gave you [ __ ]
courage huh
yeah a lot more so now you want to go
out and [ __ ] talk to girls and [ __ ]
the crazy thing is i forget that i have
men right so
my confidence goes back down
i have to like learn because it's like
it wasn't just like immediately like
immediately i knew i was like because i
it felt different and everything uh but
then now i'm so used to them like i'm
still
thinking that it was like how it was
before hey what's up in the mirror i'm
like oh
[ __ ] like it's it's different i'm just
used to covering your mouth or something
and then you get to keep my mouth closed
like when i don't really like typically
like when i talk to people to start
smiling like
giving them because now it's like if i
do people are like oh they're more
engaged and stuff so it's it's nice
smile goes a long way
yeah as soon as you got them did you
start walking the streets like
well i had to wear a face mask
everywhere oh i was locked by people
inside
yeah you're like excuse me can't cut my
teeth
i want to take you through it no so how
was your experience though so you flew
out to turkey yeah so i floated turkey
and then
um yeah so the procedure went really
quick like
how you get it done in america is a lot
it's a lot more
time that passes between and it's a lot
more expensive and the thing is like i
think like to equate like
look at any other country you go like
how much you have to pay for health
insurance
for the same quality or even better like
then you get here yeah
and like the doctors especially dentists
like i have family members our dentists
are like
the nicest cars nicest porsches biggest
houses like the most expensive parts
over there they live like modest lives
so they're not making a shit-ton off of
the teeth because
they should come here but they probably
can't get jobs out here oh yeah that's
true
but then so then it's way cheaper out
there so it was still like a good amount
i spent like around seven thousand total
um but that's like compared like fifty
thousand including the flight and yeah
with the flight like around ten say like
wait it's 50 grand if you would have got
that here
probably more [ __ ] that's a car that's a
whole ass car
no wonder they [ __ ] drive [ __ ]
portions of [ __ ] yeah over over like
six months too right because it goes
back and forth well so it takes like
sometimes like two months because over
there they have the machines to make it
and they have the technicians that work
there
here it's you have your own practice and
then they have to ship them out and do
all stuff so when it comes back it
doesn't fit they have to do all that
process
so you're basically with the fake teeth
for so long but so i went through the
first day
they like cleaned my teeth and they said
like if the gums were like
like healthy enough they can start
working immediately so then they were so
they started shaving them down
over the second i got them pretty much
uh but they numb you up the numbing was
the only painful part was it a needle or
they just rub it on there
so they rub you and then after that once
that like topical numbing agent then
they they inject every single like
every single one yeah on the top bottom
and they just start
working on like super quick like a
little [ __ ] i was like kind of like
like just when they inject me but after
that it was fine and
you're telling yourself i'm gonna be
beautiful
yeah but then they so they took the
molds of like my actual teeth before
and then after they shooting down they
put like these temporary that basically
matched my real teeth
my teeth before and then i had to wait a
few days until they built the teeth and
everything then i went in like after
five days and they like put them on they
tested them and they were like a little
off they're like a little like crooked
and stuff so they kept like
remaking the teeth um you know take a
few hours in between each time to make
this like small adjustments
and then until they're like perfect and
then they submit them in and then like
you they still have to numb you while
they cement them in
it's a little painful and then the next
day you go in and after like the numbing
is gone you can check your bite and see
like
where does it like put pressure on and
stuff like that um and then
i shave those parts down to make sure
like the bite's perfect but every part
of like the color
the shape the size everything i got to
choose from like start to finish
what if you wanted like green teeth no
but they have like
30 shades i don't know if the confidence
is going to come out
but if they have shades that are like
super dark yellow because say like some
people just need like a few
but they want to match the rest of their
teeth yeah because they drink so much
coffee and smoked cigarettes they're
like i need it to be like this yellow
so then they have and then i went like
five shades down a boy you should see
every single progression
up from this was like wider and wider
actually looks white like crazy yeah so
you're saying it gets like fluorescent
white
yeah it's like from friends the great
thing is like when i went there i picked
this one
they were like one i went for like a
natural shape uh and then they're like
everyone goes like super straight where
like their canines and everything
because like my canines are
a bit longer yeah they look natural dude
that's how my i grinded my teeth down to
be that straight and i [ __ ] hate it
i don't like it it doesn't look good nah
now they still have some shape though
a little bit yeah no because my canines
needs to be really pointy
i want wolf tea yeah sam i want some
[ __ ] like
like i like like this and [ __ ] even
animals get scared you get those kind of
teeth
especially if it's here it's gonna cost
you way too much money so
if you if you're in debt and stuff like
how would you you probably
upstart or something yeah you need
upstart and which is we're sponsored by
upstart for this video thank you guys so
much
if you guys are in turmoil in economic
turbulent times
unlike other lenders upstart can reward
you based on your education and job
history in the form of a smarter rate
you don't need a degree or diploma to
apply
that's right they let you skip going to
the bank because it's completely
online they offer loans from a thousand
to get this
fifty thousand dollars so you can
consolidate your debt into one
easy fix rate payment upstart makes it
fast and simple to check your rate since
it's just a soft pole it won't affect
your credit score the hard pull happens
if you accept your rate and proceed with
your application which is good because
you see what you're getting yourself
into first but you know what the best
part is
okay so if the loan is approved approved
accepted the most people get their funds
the very next business day that's fast
yeah
over 400 000 people have used upstart to
pay off credit cards
or meet their financial goals that's
right for yourself
from the burden of high interest credit
card debt and get back to using your
money your way with upstart okay so cy
upstart has a 4.9 out of five rating on
trustpilot
and hurry up to upstart.com record to
find out how low your
upstart rate can be checking your rate
only takes a few minutes that's
upstart.com
record nice have you tried using your
teeth on like some of the harder items
like corn
oh yeah also yeah steak was completely
fine
um i was eating corn and i was like holy
[ __ ] like i'm actually eating like
something that i would have to like
use my teeth like pull away from did it
hurt no it was completely fine there's
no pain there's no
does it feel numb like does it feel
different like you have a
different part having braces like a
phantom teeth like you know it's not
your
like you have an extra finger these are
nails
so like everything about the first day
when you put them in because they're so
smooth
um and they're like a little bit bigger
than your actual tooth would be
like on the front you can't tell but on
the back there's like it's a little bit
more rounded to fit around
it was like behind your gum a little bit
like on your gum or what
uh it's hard to see like oh that's
beautiful man
yeah the back is nice it's nice [ __ ]
they get you a new tongue too
even though that is nice you see the
back is [ __ ] up
holy [ __ ] and then uh so then you have
to show me later i can't yeah yeah don't
see how it looks when you shave down the
shave down looks crazy yeah it shows the
gory stuff
yeah but then uh before they put it like
cemented it yeah because you look like
shark teeth right basically it looks
like a little baby shark teeth
everything is fine but the first day i
got it and i was able to like eat
properly
it felt like because they're so smooth
and like a little bit bigger i felt like
they were falling out and there was like
marbles in my mouth
but it wasn't it was completely fine but
until i got like now they feel like my
real teeth
um they touching it feels like real
teeth like it doesn't feel like any
anything different when you guys see his
teeth and if you see mine do mine look
just like
[ __ ] up really [ __ ] up like extra
[ __ ] up that now that you're sitting
next to him
okay but it like it matches your face
though
i need to go turkey get my whole [ __ ]
fixed the thing is like
braces you don't put any retainers and
it's getting worse
i don't have braces on my face i know
they're struggling
braces on my face dude oh [ __ ]
that was crazy dude the the
oh
[Applause]
that's so funny look at this awesome
i think he sent it to me that should be
the thumbnail of the video
that looks crazy no recently so i'm
still doing my invisalign stuff yeah
and so recently they had to shave like
in between here and right here so right
now i actually have
for me it's a big gap right down the
middle right here and it's like that
like they had to shave it down because
then they had to like bring it together
somehow whatever yeah how was turkey
like beautiful
yeah what'd you do in between was it uh
so i was there for like 11 days
um like right when i got there the cool
thing was they give you like kova tests
and everything before you
uh get there so it's safe for them and
then also when you leave so it's just
like the airport
no the dental place oh um
but they meet you at the airport you
know when you go to their spot they pick
you up and stuff
and they take care of everything they
pick you up they drop you off wherever
during the procedure so the dental
office has like a vacation package
i know that's what it sounds like they
treat you well it's like
super [ __ ] nice super [ __ ] nice um
medical tourism is a thing
yeah and then especially in istanbul
yeah so when i was at the istanbul
airport there was a hell of people that
had like headbands to like because they
all got the hair follicle like uh
[ __ ] too they do everything everyone had
like a nose uh uh jaws and everything
but um yeah so like the first thing when
the whole ship fits
yeah some things can't be fit
and then uh but the the first day i went
i got this like
it shaved down and they put the
temporaries in it um and then
the next five days i was pretty much
because in like my jet lag and
everything so i'm still awake while
people are awake here
so i'm just working so just kind of like
jet lag no they can't do that
and then uh but then i just basically
like went out like i
i went out after i got my these teeth in
he goes he goes out with his sharp teeth
they put like fake plastic teeth in what
they look like
they look like my teeth yeah they're
like they're mixed matches did you ever
get a chance to eat with the shark teeth
because obviously no not with the shark
juice
so because because of it with the sharky
it's so you have the white part that's
enamel right yeah then when they shave
that down it's like a yellow like
inner part of your tooth that's super
[ __ ] sensitive
so it's like all your hair take it off
and touch your shark teeth uh so the
plastic teeth like sometimes they do
fall off
but it's like one whole piece right but
it was pretty hard for them to take off
they had to use a tool that was like a
hammer like hammering it out
um but when they did that and they're
putting in like the
the they see just the test and like they
had like you know when they have like
the little suction thing to like pick up
the
the saliva um that air was like hurting
because
oh yeah i'm not talking about it oh try
eating ice cream ooh that makes my
hair close up a little bit when i had to
like drink it like yeah
no i thought you're gonna say bone so
i'm like i could feel it like hurting my
jaw right so imagine just taking a bite
of ice can just through your teeth
and just holding it there with you oh
and then it goes through your nerve
system
that's how it felt do not drink like
water and stuff or like a straw
i really have to deep throat the straw
to get in the back of my throat
the things you do for beauty man wait so
did they give you like a diet
like to follow or like yeah they're like
dude you're fat
for your dude like softly
but you also need to lose some weight
dude they're like they're like
nadine i just want you to stick with
some juices and shakes and goes oh is it
because like i can't chew right now it's
nice because you're fat
no but then uh so they're like soft
foods don't eat anything too cold or too
warm you
just don't need anything um they're like
just just trying to get like soups and
stuff and then once i had these they're
like oh what can i eat
they're like you can eat everything
people are like oh you shouldn't do this
you shouldn't do that
you floss normally and [ __ ] through yeah
floss normally and then they recommend a
water floss so i bought one of those
um i recently got one those are very
weird it works so much better than a
actual flower just your tongue though
when you actually oh if you touch your
tongue but this is strong strong what's
a water floss
so imagine because i didn't like a small
jet that like you put in your mouth and
has like a little hook right
and then you use that that instead of a
floss oh
i should get that that's why i never
floss it picks up so much like
all that gunk in the corner between
their two things it like just
blasts them you don't need to brush
though yeah
oh yes no they actually i mean as far as
i know they don't recommend to fully
replace
flossing for the water i think i do both
like
dentist tells me like still go in there
sometimes but i floss like once every
four months but like i would have
i would have something stuck in my
training trying to use an actual plot
four months i can't get it
and then the water flies and it yeah
gets on immediately
once every four months did anybody just
pass through that one i heard that
no they they know how i went to the
dentist it bleeds dude like how long
when's the last time you floss
off last like every every other day and
you go like no you don't i'm like like
once a week
like no you don't i'm like i think like
six months ago he goes that was more
correct because every time you do it
it shouldn't bleed yeah but it's
probably all the tartar
build up around the gum line so they're
all [ __ ] chipping away all this like
started flossing though i do it every
day now my uh morning and night
no just once a day my dentist back home
was my cousin and
every time she would like have to clean
her teeth she would start gagging
because oh
because we wouldn't like glasses she
throw up in your mouth
and she hated when we went in because we
would be the worst you think that's just
like like popping pimples though you
know how like people like find no
that's no it's like disgusting so you
think like people's clean teeth are like
oh let me get this i want to clean it
like my friend's girlfriend
was like you don't floss do you and i'm
like how'd you know she goes
just come see me at the office she's
like i could talk all this far away
did you go i haven't gone yet i'll go
though
yeah i'll go get the water floss i'll
get the i'll i'll get it presentable so
she doesn't have to deal with so much
[Music]
tartar
you